مرحبا بكم اذا مشاهدينا الى هذه النافذه
التحليليه لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على غزه
والتداعيات ايضا في المنطقه لكن اسمحوا لي
في البدايه ان ارحب بالخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز دويري مرحبا بك
وزميلتي سلام التي نبدا معها سلام خضر اذا
في متابعه الضربات التي تعرضت لها اليمن
عاصمه صنعاء وبعض المدن اليمنيه هذه
الليله صحيح محمد فجر هذا اليوم فجر هذا
اليوم اذا تعرضت اليمن لضربات من اسلحه
مختلفه شنتها القوات البريطانيه والقوات
الامريكيه هذا تقول الدولتان ان هذه
الضربات تاتي في محاوله لتامين التجاره
الدوليه في المنطقه تحديدا في مضيق باب
المندب وفي البحر الاحمر الحوثيون كانوا
خلال الايام الماضيه منذ اندلاع حرب على
قطاع غزه نفذوا عده عمليات استهداف وقالوا
ان هذه الاستهدافات موجهه فقط ضد سفن تحمل
البضائع
التجاريه وتتجه الى الميناء الاسرائيلي
الوحيد على البحر المتوسط ميناء ايلات
طبعا هذه الخطوط تتجه من مضيق باب المندب
لتصل الى ميناء ايلات التجاري الذي تعتمد
عليه اسرائيل في عدد من في استيراد عدد من
السلع لا سما السيارات هذه الضربات اذا
التي بدات فجر هذا اليوم بعيد الثانيه
والنصف من صباح هذا اليوم استهدف عده
مناطق ولكن الاستهداف ال ربما الاكثر
كثافه كان في العاصمه صنعاء الولايات
المتحده قالت ان الاهداف شملت 16 موقعا
واستهدفت 60 هدفا في هذه المواقع ابرز
المناطق التي استهدفت في في العاصمه صنعاء
استهدف مطار صنعاء وقربه بطريقه قريبه جدا
طبعا قاعده الديلم الجويه ولكن لضرورات
تقنيه نراهما بعيدين عن بعضهما ايضا مطار
عبس تم استهدافه بالطائرات وايضا في ميناء
ومطار الحداده استخدمت
عده يعني اسلحه بالطائرات بالبوار وايضا
بال
الغواصات الامريكيه شاركت في هذه الضربه
ولكن لدينا المزيد من هذه المعلومات في
السياق السياسي لما جرى نعود اليك محمد
شكرا لك سلام اذا في السياق وكما وضحت
زميلتنا سلام خضر اعلن المجلس السياسي
الاعلى لانصار الله الحوثيين ان المصالح
الامريكيه والبريطانيه كافه اصبحت اهدافا
مشروعه ردا على الهجمات التي شنتها قوات
البلدين على مواقع يمنيه فجر اليوم اعتبر
المجلس الاعتداء امتدادا للاستهداف
الامريكي لقواتهم البحريه والعدوان على
اهل غزه وقال المجلس السياسي الاعلى
للحوثيين ان قواته ستواصل منع مرور السفن
الاسرائيليه او التي تحمل بضائعه للموانئ
الفلسطينيه المحتله وحذر الدول العربيه لا
سما دول الجوار من التورط في مسانده
الاعتداء على اليمن وفق ما جاء في البيان
الحديث عن هذه الضربات التي شاهدناها فجر
اليوم ما الذي قراته من ناحيه المواقع
المستهدفه واثر الاثر الفعلي وتاثيرها على
القدرات الحوثيه يعني كان هناك اطلاق 100
صاروخ استهدف تقريبا 16 موقع اذا لاحظنا
معظمها مطارات ونقاط انطلاق صواريخ نجدها
مثلا مطارات مطار صنعاء ومطار الديلمي في
صنعاء وهي مطارات متجاوره مطار الحديده
مطار تعز اذا هذه هي مطارات في منطقه
حجه كانت لا هي مواقع اطلاق صواريخ
وبالتالي كان هو استهدافا مباشرا لنقاط
القوه التي بيد جماعه الحوثيين من اجل
الحاق الضرر او تحجيم القدرات اذا هي
اهداف منتقى لها علاقه باليد الطوله
لجماعه الحوثيين ايضا بالنسبه ل
الصواريخ التي استخدمت سواء من البحر او
بالطائرات ولدينا الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا ايضا ما الذي قراته
ورصدته من ما هو مستخدم من مع الان نبدا
بال الحجم الاصغر بريطانيا استخدمت اربع
طائرات تايفون اقلعت من قبرص وبالتالي تم
شاركت في العمليه لكن الجانب الامريكي لا
كان الجانب الامريكي هو صاحب اليد الطوله
في هذه العمليه اي اطلق صواريخ توماهوك
وهذه الصواريخ معروفه منها من اكثر
الصواريخ تطورا في العالم
وتعتبر متميزه جدا ومعظم الدول عملت
محاكاه لها يعني هذا الصاروخ يزن 1.5 طن
تقريبا الوزن الكلي ووزن الراس الحربي 450
غم بدا يصل الى 880 غم يعمل بالجي بي اس
يطير على ارتفاع من 15 الى 100 متر وهو
يعتبر
ب بوينت تارجت يعني درجه الخطا تقاس
بال بالامتار القليله جدا وتاثيره فاعل
ومدمر فهي استخدمت اقصى قوه
واطلقت
من وسائل مختلفه اولا طلقهم
الغواصات هناك الغواصه الشهيره اللي هي
اليو اس اس فلوريدا هذه اصلا تعتبر هي
الاكبر والاضخم وتحمل على متنها بحدود 154
صاروخ اين تتمركز هذه الان لم هي تابعه
لمجموعه ال لمجموعه القتال البحري
ايزنهاور مجموعه القتال البحري ايزنهاور
هي متحركه كانت في الخليج والان هي موجوده
في البحر المتوسط فهذه قد تكون
متواجده في البحر المتوسط وقد تكون
متواجده الى الجنوب من بحر العرب و باطراف
ال المحيط الهندي لانه هذه الغواصات عاده
تبقى في المياه العميقه اكثر منها في
المياه القريبه لانه مدى الصاروخ مداه
طويل جدا وفاعل وبالتالي
اي ليس بالضروره ان تتواجد ضمن المياه
الاقليميه او قرب المياه الاقليميه ولا في
البحر الاحمر ليس ضروره لا لا لا كغواص
ستكون اما في البحر المتوسط وهذا الاحتمال
الاقل او ان تكون جنوب بحر العرب يعني
الان عندما نتحدث عن البحر العرب نحن
نتحدث عن الجزء الشمالي من المحيط ههندي
وبالتالي لن يسمى خليج عمان بحر العرب
المحيط الهندي فهي
اي فهي قد تكون في تلك في تلك تلك المناطق
كذلك اطلقت صواريخ من
مدمره المدمره اللي هي ارليف بيرك وكذلك
هذه تحمل حوالي 76 صاروخ توما هوك استخدمت
طائرات اف 18 من على حامله الطائرات
ايزنهاور اذا هي بعمليه واسعه النطاق وا
عندما نتحدث عن 100 صاروخ بغض النظر
الغالبيه العظمى توماهوك او هناك استخدام
لصواريخ اخرى من الطائرات لانه الطائرات
الطائرات العاديه لا تحمل صواريخ توماهوك
هذه تحمل بالقاذفات بي 2 او بي 52 بينما
يطلق عاده هو من الغواصات ومن المدمرات
وقد البي 52 والبي 2 قد تحمله هذا
استخدمته الولايات المتحده لكن ماذا عن
بريطانيا البريطانيا استخدمت الصواريخ
المباشره ما تشبه صواريخ لهل الفاير اللي
هي تستخدم صواريخ جو ارض نعم امامنا
الخريطه وانت تعرف المنطقه الجيده انت
خدمت دكتور في هذه هذه المنطقه نحن نتحدث
ا عن مساحه طويله
يعني مساحه عمل عسكري بالنسبه للحوثيين هي
طويله كيف بالامكان ان تؤثر مثل هذه
الضربات على مناطق معينه على قدرات قد
تكون ابسط من من ذلك هذا يعيد نا الى ما
جرى باليمن منذ عام
2015 يعني وكان هناك اطلاق صواريخ
باستمرار على الاهداف في داخل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكانت هناك حمله جويه
محمومه لسنوات من قبل الامارات والسعوديه
وفي البدايه كان كان تحالف ضد الحوثيين
ومن ثم التحالف تقلص وبقي على السعوديه
والامارات ولكن لم تتوقف اطلاق الصواريخ
الا من خلال المفاوضات يعني رغم غم كل
الجهد الذي بذل من اجل الحاق التدمير
الكامل والنهائي استمر اطلاق الصواريخ حتى
تم التوافق سياسيا وبالتالي الان لا اتوقع
دكتور فقط توضيح للسؤال
المسافه هذه الساحل طويل اقصد قدرات
الحوثيين هل من الممكن او اي جماعه في هذه
المساحه ان
تتاثر هذا بفعل وجود يعني سواء المضيق او
هذه المساحه
هذا هذا هذا ما قصدته السواحل اليمنيه
السواحل اليمنيه تزيد عن 2200 م م انت يجب
ان تنظر ليس فقط الى سواحل البحر الاحمر
يجب ان تنظر الى سواحل
ال المدمره كلكل اين استهدفت في منائي عدن
نعم في منائي عدن اذا في الجنوب في البحر
العرب وبالتالي الم يتم استهداف بعض
الاهداف مقابل السواحل الغربيه للهند الم
يتم استهداف اي سفن في خليج عمان اذا انا
بدي انظر ل الخارطه اليمنيه لن انظر الى
مسافه ال من باب المندب الى الحدود مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا انا التركيز
الرئيسي سيكون ما قبل ما قبل المضيق ثم هي
ال الاعلان الحوثي جاء ديق تقصد خليج عدن
وما ي خليج عدن يمتد حتى حدود عمان ام حتى
ظفار حتى حدود ظفار هذه من حدود ظفار لباب
المندب حتى حدود المك العربيه السعوديه
اكثر من 2200 م م طول
الشواطئ المنطقه البحر الاحمر اذا التي
تركز فيها العمليات المنطقه الاخرى عمليات
محدوده هذه المنطقه
مليئه بالموانئ الصغيره التي ما هو ما هي
قدرات الحوثي انا هنا السؤال ما الذي
يمتلكه ما الذي يمتلكه الحوثي حتى اجيبك
على سؤالك ما هي قدرات
الحوثي في هذا المجال اولا يمتلك صواريخ
بر بحر عاصف اثنين
ومواصفات العامه لا اقول التاثير والدقه
من حيث الوزن والطول وما شابه ذلك هذ طوله
10 متر وتقريبا وزنه 1100 كيلو ووزن
والوزن المتفجرات 550 م واقصى مدى له 400
م م وبالتالي الان هذا يعتبر صاروخ عاصف
اثنين يوجد عندهم صاروخ المندب اثنين وهو
استنساخ عن صاروخ صيني عن صاروخ
صيني ومداه 300 كيلومتر لديه الصواريخ
البالستيه لديه الطائرات المسيره لديه
الزوارق الحربيه السريعه المفخخه اذا لديه
عده وسائل يستطيع من خلالها
لكن الاعلان الاعلان الحوثي كان واضحا هو
هدد في البدايه بمنع السفن التي تحمل
العلم الاسرائيلي او مملوكه لاسرائيل نعم
هذا في الخطوه الاولى نعم الخطو وربط ذلك
برفع الحصار عن غزه قال كما تحاصر انت غزه
وتمنع
ال سيارات الوقود والطعام ان تدخل لاطفال
غزه سافرد عليك حصارا ثم بعد ذلك وسع اطار
الحصار وقال كل سفينه تحمل مواد تتجه الى
موانئ فلسطين المحتله وسان تذك حكت ان هذا
الممر يستخدم ل لمنا ايلات لا هو يستخدم
لكل المطار الموانئ الفلسطين المحتله سدوت
وحيفا غيرها كلها معظم الصفن تذهب من هذه
من هذه الطريق ولانها اقرب من ان تاتي من
مسافات اخرى
فبالتالي هو
ربط عدم التعرض للملاحه البحريه ذات
العلاقه بالكيان الاسرائيلي مع رفع الحصار
عن غزه هو لم يهدد السفن هذا ما ما صرح به
وهذا ما حدث على ارض الواقع لو عدنا الى
المقدرات التي تمتلكها جماعه الحوثي في
على طول هذه المنطقه ما قدرات حمايه هذه
الصواريخ واخفائها والتعامل مع مع قصف
الان امريكي بريطاني يا سيدي ما قلت لك
الحمله الجويه السعوديه الاماراتيه خمس
سنوات ولم تستطع منع الحوثي من اطلاقه
لماذا لانه الجغرافيا تخدم
الحوثي الجغرافيا تخدم
الحوثي الان منطقه حجه على سبيل المثال
الى
ال الشمال الشرقي من الحديده والى الجنوب
الغربي من صنعاء منطقه حجه تستطيع ان تخفي
فيها جيوش لمن يعرفها الجغرافيا اليمنيه
معقده وصعبه جدا اذا تحدثنا عن منطقه
صعدا تحديدا اكثر منطقه جبال مران منطقه
جبال مران لوحدها تتفوق على جبال على تورا
بورا في افغانستان من حيث تعقيد الجغرافيا
وبالتالي ليس من السهوله
بمكان القضاء على قدرات الحوثي هو قال امس
انه اخلى المواقع واستطاع تامين الاسلحه ن
وهذا متوقع جدا لانه من 48 ساعه خاصه
الجانب البريطاني خاصه الجانب البريطاني
يتحدث عن احتماليه الضربه فبالتالي هو
تلقى انذار منذ 48 ساعه والمعروف عن ال
اليمنيين اي يعني تاريخيا معروفين بالذكاء
وبالتالي يلتقطوا الرساله مباشره ولهم
تجربه امتدت لحوالي سبع سنوات من من
الصراع مع دول الجوار وبالتالي كانت تنقذ
ما يمكن انقاذه لا اقول كل شيء ل لم لم
ينقذ كل شيء ولم يدمر كل
شيء دكتور شكرا لك حتى اللحظه فيما يتعلق
باليمن وما تم استهدافه من مواقع الان
ننتقل الى غزه
ولمتابعه التطورات هنالك والمناطق هذه هي
الخريطه اذا دكتور فايز المناطق التي ما
زالت تستهدف في قطاع غزه وهو كما واضح عبر
المراسلين ايضا على الارض من الشمال حتى
الجنوب لكن في التحركات البريه ما الذي
تقراه من تحركات اليوم
الجمعه حتى من يوم الخميس نعم لانه لا
يوجد فارق كبير ما بين الامس واليوم في
تطور المعارك وبالتالي هي استمرار الان ل
ننظر الى المنطقه الشماليه من الطريق رقم
10 حتى السياج لا يوجد احداث رئيسيه خلال
ال 36 ساعه
الماضيه لا يوجد حدث رئيسي فقط حظه غزه
والشمال انا اتحدث من الطريق رقم 10 حتى
ال السياج شمال بيت حانون والعطا طره هذه
المنطقه لا لا لم يحدث بها حدث رئيسي ال
لكن النشاط الذي زاد عن معدله
الطبيعي عمليات
الاستطلاع تحديدا استخدام الطائرات الدرون
وطائرات الكواد وطائرات الكواد التي
تستخدم الان هي طائرات الكواد ليس
للاستطلاع انما طائرات هجوميه وبدا توظيف
للاحلال مكان القناصه هذا بما يتعلق في
المنطقه الشماليه اذا ذهبنا الى المنطقه
الوسطى منطقه المخيمات نعم منطقه المخيمات
لا يزال القتال مستمر منذ ان بدات معركه
هذه المعركه تولتها قياده الفرقه 36 تم
سحبها كقيادي كمسؤول وتم اسناد الواجب الى
الفرقه 99 يوجد اربعه الويه معززه بقوات
نخبه لواء مظليين لواء جفعاتي ولواي دروع
ملخص العمليه بصوره عامه لا يزال هناك
اصرار على تقسيم او حدوث احداث مناطق
فاصله ما بين المخيمات
الاربعه من اجل تسهيل العمليات لكن ملخص
المعارك البريج لا يزال متماسك ومنذ ان تم
دحر القوات الاحتلال لم تستطع ان تعود مره
اخرى هي تقريبا بالعشرات او مئات الامتار
من الجانب الجنوبي وحتى منطقه يطلق عليها
منطقه
المقبره اذا ذهب الى ان صيرات كذلك الهجوم
من المنطقه الشماليه بمسافه ضيقه جدا
المغازي احدث اقترا اختراق يقدر 600 متر
من الجانب الغربي
وبالتالي هناك مناوره من اجل فصل المخيمات
عن منطقه رفح لماذا لانه اذا يعتقدوا ان
هناك عن منطقه دير البلح تقص عن منطقه دير
البلح عذرا عن منطقه دير البلح لانهم
يعتقدوا نعم نعم بان قاعده الفاع البه
الرئيسيه هي المخيمات عن دير البلح فاذا
ما تم السيطره عليها ولا اعتقد ذلك هذا قد
يفضي الى تسهيل المهم اللاحقه في منطقه
دير البلح لان تقريبا هي ورفح تعتبر خارج
اطار المعارك الحاسمه منذ بدايه العمليه
اذا ذهبنا الى منطقه الجنوب الى منطقه خان
يونس كان هناك عمليه انسحاب من المحطه
والقرار والانسحاب تم سحب تقريبا اربعه
الويه وتم سحبها الى شرق طريق صلاح الدين
على طريق كيسوفيم من اجل اعاده تاهيلها
واعاده رفع جاهزيه القتاليه واعاده
توظيفها في مكان ما اذا ذهبنا الى شرق الى
داخل مدينه خان يونس هناك ثلاثه نقاط
اشتباك منذ اكثر من اربعه ايام في
منطقه المحطه والمقبره والسجن
المحطه والكتيبه والسجن و والقتال دائر
فيها على مدار الساعه في المنطقه الشرقيه
بعد الانسحاب من القراره
وازنه يتركز القتال في الخطوط الشرقيه
وهناك محاوله محمومه من اجل الاحداث
اختراق كبير يصل الى طريق صلاح الدين
نشاهد الان ما بثته سرايا القدس وهي مشاهد
طبعا من تفجير عناصرها كما تقول حق
الغام واستهداف خط مسير قوه مشاه
اسرائيليه جنوب وشرق مدينه غزه نتابع معك
لواء فايز وانت شاهدت هذا
الفيديو هنالك استهداف لاليات واستهداف ل
مسير في في دقيقه ما الذي تلاحظه في هذا
الفيديو الان عمليه تحضير حشوات عمليه
تحضير حشوات هذا الاسلاك الكورتكس
سيقوم بتوضع الحشوه يعني ربما من اللافت
اننا ما زلنا نتحدث عن جنوب شرق مدينه غزه
هذا ما قلته قبل ان يبدا العرض قلت لك
بدات من الجانب الشرقي اعاده بناء القوه
كم عدد القوه التي تقاتل من اقصى عبسان من
الشمال
حتى اقصى عبسان الجنوبيه شامله بني سيلا
القوه وصلت في لحظه ما الى 8 الويه عفوا
دكتور فقط هذا شرق هذا جنوب شرق مدينه غزه
يعني نتحدث طبعا اتحدث عن نفس الزيتون جحر
الديك هذه المناط جنوب شرق مدينه غزه هذا
في جحر الديك ليس في خان يونس نعم نعم هذا
ه هذه النقطه التي اردت ان اوضحها نتحدث
عن المدينه مدينه غز جنوب الشرق نتحدث عن
الزيتون او الزيتون وجحر الديك الزيتون
وجحر الديك العمليات سواء كانت في شرق خان
يونس او في تلك المنطقه هي عمليات متماثله
وانا استخدمت كلمه جحر الديك لشاره الى
القراره لانه القراره كادت ان تصبح جحر
الديك رقم اثنين وبالتالي هي نفس العم هي
نفس العمليات والعمليات متماثله وعمليه
انشاء حقول الالغام هذه تكون بناء على خطه
تم تصورها مسبقا لاستدراج القوات الى هذه
النقطه اللواء فايز دوير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي